blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman of the people is a new platform
matching local campaigns with supporters
and donors from across the country
sort of like a yelp for local candidates
you can filter by policy and location
and you can support the next generation
of leaders check it out at of the
people.us
as joe biden's presidency becomes more
and more
popular i think i would call it in terms
of joe biden having
the highest initial approval rating of
any president in 28 years high support
for the coveted relief bill high support
for
joe biden's management of coronavirus as
that happens
republicans are becoming more and more
unhinged
in their characterizations of the biden
presidency yesterday
i played a clip for you of trumpian
congresswoman lauren bobert
saying that the equality act supported
by joe biden and democrats is an example
of
gay lesbian and trans vex hike
i'm not saying it wrong it's a crate
it's not a real word but this is what
she said
transvex hike supremacy a two nights ago
on the tucker carlson program tucker
hosted former speaker of the house
congressman newt gingrich
they now are framing the goals of the
democratic party and joe biden
as a domination of christians and jews
by uh i i guess trans people
it's all crazy and bizarre let's get
into the first clip
gingrich is the former speaker of the
house he's a very smart man and we
thought we'd invite him on tonight and
ask him what is going on here why did
biden pick the most divisive policies
up front mr speaker thanks for coming on
tonight what do you think we're watching
here what's going on
now this is already a lie joe biden
didn't pick the most divisive policies
up front
joe biden's first focus was covid trump
failed on kovat trump probably lost
because of his handling of covid
joe biden ran on here's what i would do
on kovid and the things he did on day
one
via executive order were all popular
with the country even with many
republicans you see it reflected in joe
biden's high covet approval rating
most of the country wants the covet
stimulus bill which republicans don't
want
so tucker is lying but let's now listen
to newt gingrich's explanation
well you know it occurred to me that
biden had lived through two
democratic disasters when clinton was
elected
two years later they lost 54 seats and
we became
a majority for the first time in 40
years when obama was elected
two years later they lost 63 seats
and i think what they've done is a very
calculating and i think cynical ploy
which is they've they've given up on
keeping the house what they're doing is
ramming through
everything they can get done before they
lose in 2022.
so this is kind of a sprint to
radicalism
uh even though it's going to cost if you
look at these votes in the house
you've got 30 40 50 members who are not
going to be able to go home and defend
them
they're not going to be able to explain
it and i think that the biden harris
model is
we're going to lose the house anyway we
might as well grab everything we can
while we got the power
now some aspect of that might be true
but what newt is missing in his analysis
is that historically it's common that
when a party wins the white house
in the next midterm they lose the house
or at least
lose seats in the house if not lose it
altogether it's not unique to only one
administration
typically democrats take the white house
from republicans
two years later they lose seats and
maybe even lose the house
the inverse typically is also true the
idea
that biden has written off the house of
representatives in 22
it's silly and again the things biden uh
uh is doing are popular
they're not radical let's continue here
it gets really crazy tucker carlson
frames up the question in a completely
dishonest way
but somehow newt gingrich makes it even
nuttier i i gotta wonder though and i
your analysis makes total sense and and
you've i mean you know you ran the house
so you know how it works
but i just wonder the motive behind the
things that they want you said they want
to get the stuff they they want up front
makes total sense but all the things
that they want
hurt the country in measurable ways
we're energy independent
they want us not to be they they want to
totally destroy our control over the
border they're letting foreign nationals
roam the country unimpeded with kovid
like why would you want those things
yeah i mean i just did a tweet this
afternoon saying if there's a problem
with coveted in texas
it's not governor abbott it's biden's
illegals
and we don't we just had a column these
are biden's illegals
coming in the country no public health
check i mean even back in the 1880s
we had public health checks oh yeah if
you came to america
but but here's tucker i really admire
your show
i really think you're remarkably
trenchant in your insights
but i just want to offer you a thought
they don't want to protect your america
they want to create an alternative
america it's an america
of of racial uh deep
inequality and an anti-white and by the
way anti-asian basis
it's an america in which transgender
dominates christianity
and judaism i don't know that i've ever
seen
more red meat dog whistle sort of coded
language there
newt gingrich says that what democrats
want
is an anti-white country also anti-asian
now
that's a shout out to the white
supremacists who often defend themselves
on so-called race realism stuff where
they say
it's not even about white people being
the smartest asians are
even smarter than white people that
that's a that's a
typical line you see on purpose or not
newt gingrich is shouting them out but
then the inclusion of judaism is very
pernicious
newt gingrich and other right-wing
christians they love to pay
lip service to jews and judaism and talk
about a judeo-christian philosophy
as if judaism is a big piece of that and
they're supportive of israel in a very
particular way and they pretend to be
supportive of jews
it's all a ruse for their religious
beliefs
in which they believe that supporting
israel in a particular way
will bring about the second coming of
jesus christ any time you hear people
like newt gingrich and others
appear to go out of the way to support
jews or include jews in what they're
talking about or defend jews
it's because it plays a particularly
self-serving role in their christian
supremacist worldview
and of course the mere idea of
transgender people
dominating christians and jews as if the
two things have anything to do with each
other
it's absurd it's wacky and it's a
perfect example
of how tucker carlson's populist
rhetoric can be appealing
it can lull you into a sense of maybe
there's something good there
and then this is the type of stuff that
he brings on and promotes
we covered earlier this week that texas
made the decision to open the state
wide open let her rip canceling all
guidelines getting rid of the mask
mandate too
now of course there's been pushback and
people saying this is incredibly
premature
it doesn't make any sense so now the
texas governor and lieutenant governor
are shifting into saying it's
undocumented immigrants and it's also
joe biden to blame for covid
in texas now you might remember that all
throughout donald trump's presidency
trump and texas republicans were saying
wow thanks to trump we've shut down
illegal border crossings border
crossings are at record lows
the wall which they didn't build has
stopped border crossings crossings
couldn't possibly be lower
that's not inconvenient anymore now they
need something to blame for covid
so the border crossings that they
stopped
those border crossings are now to blame
for covet and texas
here's republican texas governor greg
abbott earlier this week on fox news
the biden administration was releasing
illegal immigrant
illegal immigrants into our communities
who had coveted
the bite administration was spreading
covid in
south texas yesterday because of their
lack of constraint
of testing and quarantining people who'd
come across the border illegally
the bright administration was exposing
texans to covet
that is neanderthal type approach to
dealing with the kova situation
that is just barely coherent if you were
wondering did i have a brain glitch did
i misunderstand that no
it's just barely coherent and then
yesterday morning here's republican
texas lieutenant governor dan patrick
who previously said
grandma's willing to die for the stock
market saying pretty much the same thing
on fox news
and as governor abbott mentioned i would
call neanderthal thinking
of allowing people to cross the border
illegally with kovid
tested positive and put them on a bus
allowing people to cross the border what
is he talking about they're just going
to keep repeating this lie over and over
again
as usual and while they're i mean listen
windmills push air around
covid's a respiratory illness i don't
know you're pushing all that air around
maybe that leads to infections too
now to attach some facts to all of this
first of all
biden isn't letting anyone in biden's
been president for five weeks
biden's presidency has had very little
effect one way or another on coveted
cases so far
other than ramping up vaccination which
is starting to have an effect on cases
second mexico's per capita coveted case
rate
is about one-sixth that of the united
states in other words
the odds that someone coming from mexico
has covered
are one-sixth of the the odds that a
random american has coveted and in any
case
if greg abbott really believed this that
immigrants were bringing coveted to
texas from mexico
it still wouldn't make sense to cancel
the mass mandate and open everything
you'd want to be protecting texans
from those supposed mexicans bringing
covet over which isn't happening anyway
it was 100 predictable that they were
going to pull this
they are pulling it and lots of texans
gleeful for the removal of guidelines or
going with it
many texans are not happy with what's
going on
and uh there's an entire other twitter
movement that is behind saying
we do not support what greg abbott is
doing maybe we'll get to that later on
in the show
let's take a quick break find me on
twitter at deep hackman the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the show remember we are
a program
mostly funded by members who sign up at
joinpakman.com
this is a great day every day is a great
day for a new membership
and i encourage you to grab one today
let's hear from some of the people in
our audience we are taking calls today
via discord you can join
the david pakman show discord at
davidpakman.com
discord it is a great place to be
let's go first here to
uh let's go to stephanie from richardson
texas which has just announced they are
opening everything
they are stopping masking they are doing
so many different things stephanie
what's going on down there
hi can you hear me yes i can wonderful
excellent i
love your show i discovered you during
quarantine i just want to start by
saying that
thank you for taking my call pleasure um
yeah i'm so glad you took my call this
is a
first time i've done something like this
and i am calling to speak on um
being absolutely beside myself for uh
the unmasking mandate
i'm a little freaked out actually so so
here was my question on this stephanie
my
my belief was in a segment i did when
when the news broke about this
i said this is crazy irresponsible you
know only seven percent of texans are
vaccinated it's just far too early
however on i i have a sense that
the people that don't care about the
guidelines we're already
ignoring them in texas anyway and that
people that do
are going to keep wearing masks anyway
like is is there some truth to that
yeah that's actually my hope i really
i'm i'm hoping that
as startling as the news was i'm really
hoping that
we will maintain as we have been because
right as you've seen
in a lot of the reports it is a lot like
that people who aren't gonna mask
aren't gonna mask even though there was
a mandate in place
and those of us who've chosen to keep
doing that we'll keep doing that my only
my only real concern is that um
the uh our texas education agency that's
run by
a software person not an educator
hopefully will follow the guidelines and
keep the mass mandates in place at
school because i do have a daughter in
middle school so
i'm really hoping that that will be the
they'll follow the guidelines and be
smart about it because obviously you
know
a lot of parents are concerned about
that but yeah i mean that's kind of my
hope too though
that is that um a lot of the people who
are
continuing to follow the guidelines will
keep doing that i don't think those of
us who've been doing it
all oh yeah let's just not you know i'm
still not gonna go to restaurants i'm
still not going to go you know unmasked
so it's just like i'm hoping the rest of
us are going to be in the same boat
basically now when you say that a lot of
people were ignoring the mass guidelines
anywhere
anyway in some states with mask mandates
if you go into a business without a mask
you get kicked out in texas is it more
of like a look the other way type of
thing
yes yeah basically yeah it's kind of
like upsetting because i've been
in places that have like you know the
mass mandate
requirement on the door but then i go in
there and i see people without a mask
and it's fortunately not like
it's less often than not i guess i
should say but it's like when i see
someone i'll turn around just go the
other way
and you know do my like i was mostly at
the grocery store and i'll just shop in
another aisle but
yeah it's it's not i'm not seeing any of
those things that like people post on
social media or whatever about people
freaking out about masks you know in
stores they don't really do that because
they don't really
the store unders don't do a lot to
enforce it so it's like you know that's
a little frustrating but again
like i said it's not happening all the
time so it's good and i don't see any
real drama but i just kind of
go in a different aisle and continue my
shock and let me ask you this
are there places where if you go in with
a mask
you are looked at like you're the crazy
one yeah absolutely
actually it's um funny because i mostly
i do research and i shop at low
hours and i and low capacity hours or
whatever and i um
and i uh go places that have a mandate
but my husband goes to a place
locally that is an independently owned
business
and the guy does not require you wear a
mask and he says
he'll wear his mask in there and guy
will yell at him like take it off he's
like i'm not gonna
do that see that's crazy that's crazy
take it off
it's like he's kind of half joking but
not really but he knows
it's like a business owner he knows so
he's not gonna like you know
he's gonna my husband's gonna do what
he's gonna do but he's like i said i
wouldn't go in there
right right right right so it's like it
is it's there's people they're just like
it's just it's so
crazy and there's people that just like
it's like i my whole attitude this whole
time has been it's like the least
thing you can do you know it's just it's
the minimum requirements where
yeah it's such an easy thing it's like
you just you know okay you want to open
businesses make sense but they're just
wearing a mask is so easy
well listen stephanie thanks for the
update on what's going on down there and
stay
safe thanks you too i appreciate it all
right stephanie from texas
great to hear from her why don't we go
next
to let's go to horse from illinois horse
from illinois around the air
horse from illinois please unmute and
then you'll be able to talk to me
horse from illinois you're on the air
and last chance for horse from illinois
you are on the air
all right no more horse three three
shots is it uh let's go to kyle from
daytona beach next kyle from daytona
beach florida you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
excellent thank you so much for taking
my call
pleasure so down here in florida uh
things have basically been wide open um
the entire pandemic on the right you
you've covered
desantis's handling of of the pandemic
but
what's what's concerning me is the
the chatter that that i'm hearing from
my neighbors
um i'm actually a former white
supremacist and
i can i can say without uh any shadow of
a doubt that the rhetoric
coming from the right um shadows
the agenda of the white supremacist
movement you know 1488
rehoa uh racial holy war and all that
and when i saw the the odell rune
at cpac it it really shocked me because
after so many instances of
of references to white supremacy from
the right
yeah um it's not a coincidence
it can't be you think so let me just
make sure everybody knows what you're
talking about
so at cpac if you looked at the shape of
the stage from above
it looked like this i mean you it's a
white supremacist symbol but what is the
symbol exactly
it's an odell roon and and
i hope people don't get it confused with
the with the um
religious symbols of the elder futhark
and uh you know pagan religious
practices this odel rune is is
a a modified othalla
and there there were mysticists
in germany um in the 1930s that came to
prominence and
uh foremost of which was uh um
von list guido von list and
he he put a twist on
the traditional religious runes
and uh the nazis took these
uh bastardized runes and ran with them
uh the the odell rune is one of these
bastardized runes
that you know came about through
mysticism and through the uh
emphasis of you know a germanic heritage
that
the the third reich emphasized and you
just don't think there's any chance that
that's a coincidence at cpac
well there's absolutely no way just like
when uh the former president referenced
henry ford's medic
uh yeah exactly how are you gonna
reference an obscure anti-semitic text
if if you're not a part of the white
supremacist movement
and i've i've actually i've actually had
to meet with
uh gang sergeants in the county that i
live in
to to get my name
out of all of this insanity yeah so i
was going to ask you that so when
you say you're a former white
supremacist were you part of an
organized group or you were like
just a general white supremacist
no the american nazi party i was patched
a full member
wow and how did you get out
my my mother's
my my mother's from tennessee but her
father was a professor and he marched
during the civil rights movement and
when i started to go farther and farther
right
now keep in mind this is a woman who
raised me on rush limbaugh
right but when she but when she started
to hear white supremacist rhetoric that
she recognized
she told me that that's that's not how
we live
and that the end that that's and that's
not right and she
would quote the gospels you know the red
words from the new testament
and uh what's what's what's really wild
um about all this is that uh the
majority of white supremacists
believe that uh white people
are actually jews and that jews
are are fake jews because ev you know ev
everybody wants to be the chosen people
right
yeah white supremacists generally
believe that
uh the tribe of dan
or the lost tribe of judah somehow went
to denmark
um the danes you know dan i don't know
how they make that connection
it's not based on science or history or
dna
but they say oh well we're the lost
tribe
of judah and we're the actual jews
and my mom started pointing out
the insanity you know um
how can you be anti-semitic and
claim to be jewish it's all pretty
incoherent yeah and so so but
just in in summary because we do have
limited time so how old were you
when you got into being a white
supremacist and how old when you got out
in my early 20s and i got out in my
uh early 30s okay that's a decade yeah
yeah it was it i spent the first part
being heavily indoctrinated in about the
last half
um you know very
very confused about everything until
logic and reason
uh overtook the indoctrination yeah but
what i'm
what i'm concerned about is
the future of our country when so many
of my neighbors
and even uh my mom actually told me
this past weekend people at the church
where i grew up the i mean people at the
church
that i grew up at are are spewing
anti-semitic rhetoric racist rhetoric
far-right rhetoric
and and they're bible thumpers no you're
right to uh you're right to be concerned
kyle i
am glad you got out of it and i
appreciate the call i do have to move on
let's let's plan to speak
again uh because there are there are
lots of folks hoping to
uh chat today let's go next
to kalyn from niagara
kalyn you're on the air you can hear me
yes i can
hi thanks for taking my call thank you
um
i'm interested in the um the security
around the
state capital and i'm
kind of wondering why it's still there
and how long
it would stay for which state which
state cap are you saying in new york
where you are
no i'm actually this is the washington
state couple i'm actually in canada
niagara
washington state or washington dc dc
sorry oh okay all right so the the the
the capital the federal capital you're
concerned about how long they're going
to stay there
yeah i i've been people have been
emailing me about this
i don't know the answer i mean you know
this week they were supposedly still
there because
um march 4th was the day when trump was
going to supposedly become president
again according to some q anon people
uh i i don't know i mean like on the
record
what they're supposedly there for is
just to disincentivize anything like
even trying anything like what went down
on january 6th but
certain point you got to start paring it
down you know and that was part of my
question
is that do you think they would
the administration or whoever is in
charge of keeping them there would keep
them there
as an optic yeah to say that
this part of the right wing is a
dangerous threat
and if everybody sees the security
around it
continuing on throughout the year they
will continue to think
okay maybe there is a continued threat
to the building or to whatever that
they're trying to dissuade
yeah i mean i think it could more be
optics as well
i think you're you could be right the
problem is that there's also
you know the right is pointing to it and
saying
this is joe biden's police state america
and they're building antipathy
by it so i don't know that the optics
are necessarily
all good yeah that makes sense
although i don't think uh they would
think about it in that way
yeah but it seems like they're more
thinking about it inside of their own
framework i think you're right you care
about what the other side thinks
everybody will see it for what they they
want it to be my view is i understand
why
why it started on january 6th although a
few hours too late
and i'd love to have a sense of what the
plan is
and uh for for how long this is going to
be the the status quo
in washington dc do you think they were
embarrassed that they weren't ready
for january 6 and then maybe yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay well thank you for taking
my call i really appreciate it this is
the first time
and i really appreciate your program
thank you so much kailyn from niagara
very much appreciate it let's take a
quick break
if you are holding on discord don't hang
up because we are going to take more
calls after this very short break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
i recently mentioned our partnership
with the youtube channel
nerds for humanity and the team behind
that channel has built a new website
called of the people
which you can find at of the people.us
and they're one of our sponsors today
fascinating website basically like a
yelp
for local political candidates you can
browse
and search for candidates based on
policy location and background
the key insight from of the people is
that all national politics starts local
and by making it easier to discover and
support everyday folks
running for city council or state
assembly county commissioner
in your community you can help incubate
the talent that will become
future congressional representatives
senators
even presidents if you're a candidate
running for local office set up a
profile on otp
it's free and you can attract exposure
and donors
and everyone else go support this
grassroots platform i put a link
underneath this video
and while you're at it don't forget to
subscribe to the nerds for humanity
youtube channel
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
let's go next to jacob from nebraska
jacob from nebraska you're on the air
hello can you hear me
yes i can you do sound like you're under
underground but i can hear you
okay good good i promise i'm not on the
ground okay as long as you're not
it's fine to sound that way yeah
how are you doing i'm doing well thank
you uh so i'm i'm from nebraska
and the nebraska democratic party is
notoriously bad at like existing
period okay so how do you how does the
democratic party
kind of appeal and get beyond the social
issues that really hold the
nebraska people i think in a place like
nebraska
the i don't think democrats win by
trying to
convince people on social issues i think
democrats win particularly at the local
level
by showing how the last i mean you could
say
20 30 or even 40 years of right-wing
economics
have economically ravaged many
middle america states i don't know
enough about nebraska to know exactly
what the source of some of the economic
strife is
but i would if i were working in
nebraska as a democratic activist i
would i would figure that out
and i would focus almost exclusively on
economic issues
and make the social issues um secondary
or even tertiary
to campaigns i i'm not saying it would
work but that's how i would approach
nebraska if i was trying to elect
democrats
awesome well thank you so much i've been
listening for a long time
i've been a member for a long time i
really enjoy the show
so thank you thank you so much very much
appreciate the call
let's talk next to um
let's go to why don't we go to darren
from the united kingdom darren you're on
the air
david how are you i'm doing well thank
you
thanks for the call back my second
attempt so um i wanted to ask you
about the fight of the evangelical
church in the
in the us because uh um i'm a christian
uh um i'm from the uh the episcopalian
background
a church of england and and i'm seeing
uh quite a lot of uh false prophets
charlatans and the other wells in the
church in england
really yeah so what's your opinion about
the uh
the evangelical episcopalian church in
the us i don't know much about the
episcopalian
episcopalian evangelical church in the
u.s to be quite frank i
am uh i i know that they are quite
different than for example the catholic
church but
for me it's i i wouldn't even be able to
tell you
the defining characteristics of american
episcopalianism versus being a methodist
or a baptist i
i it's it's sort of beyond me what i
know is that across
all sects we do seem to be seeing
a resurgence in the sort of uh
prophets and future tellers some of the
apocalyptic stuff
um they've basically all been completely
wrong about everything they they
predicted about the 2020 election for
sure
i mean in england what are the defining
characteristics of the
of the english episcopalian church
well we've we've gone through a
transition so we uh we are quite
inclusive now
so we're we're breaking down barriers
with uh with lgbtq plus
and and ethnic minorities would want to
be open and fair
uh but uh but but there's been a bit of
resurgence with uh
you know we've had uh there's some some
sort of false prophets of
gaslighting um and blasphemers
and even in my church it was nearly
uh corrupted completely by by these
people with their own
hidden agenda in your church
darren what is an example of the
prophecy that was being spewed
um i had a dream last night and god told
me
blah blah blah blah so but what would be
an example like what types of prophecy
are they trying to put out there
i mean it's it's a it's just to
manipulate people to their own ends
uh grooming really
it's a form of grooming spiritual abuse
that's what it okay but is i'm just one
maybe there isn't is there a specific
example of a particular prophecy that
was sort of told to you
uh oh yes i mean because um i suffer
from a
mental health illness um in my life i've
got a bit of a stammer as you can tell
and um and i was told that
uh that to these were punishments from
god
because of my sin and my lack of
righteousness
and that is clearly not biblical
teaching that that is not gospel
teaching
at all um that that's a perversion
they blasphemy of the teaching of christ
to manipulate me to put me down now
darren when you were told that did that
help you in any way
oh well i mean i was filled with a
righteous and righteous indignation
to to to fight back to to repel
to uh to be and uh and i stayed in that
church for six years
surrounded by people who didn't like me
at all and i saw them out in the end
wow so but but in other words being told
that the explanation for
your issues was that you had sinned and
it was punishment from god that didn't
help you deal with the issues
when i could see it was a lie from the
straight from right
it was it was a complete lie from the
office i could see that right so
so perhaps i was blessed in that respect
you were able to know right away you
were being fed nonsense
yes yes but i can see other people in
england and in the us who are being
played
and they don't know it no yeah
wow well darren i'm sorry to hear that i
really appreciate you calling in and
sharing your story though
yeah thanks for the call back great show
all right thanks there it is darren from
the united kingdom
wow things are getting very very real
very real there
let's talk next to let's go to
luis from chicago illinois
hi david hello um
i'm just wondering like i've seen your
discussions with people like tim poole
and
um then
uh what up just people from the right
so i'm just wondering if there's gonna
be more discussions like that in the
future
maybe i mean i don't know you know one
of the reasons i've got
gotten away from doing it is that i
i find that it's extraordinarily
unproductive
to engage with just sort of like bad
faith actors
in performative debate like i know
i know it does well in terms of clicks
and i know it's like
fun and funny but i i don't know that
i'm really doing much to sort of like
advance
the cause of really thinking deeply
about issues and that type of thing and
there's so often cancellations people
are so flaky you know i plan my schedule
around these things and then people
don't show up and
i don't know i mean i'm always as a
general thing like yeah i'm up
to to uh up for talking with people
but i i just don't know i i don't know i
i guess i'm ambivalent
okay thank you would you like to see
more of that i mean give me your sense
um yeah it's kind of fun and then it's
fun
right but do we learn from it is the
question
i feel like it kind of encourages you to
um got them to contradict themselves and
yeah kind of exposes them but i don't
know but i guess that's what i mean like
if tim poole comes on like when tim
poole came on and he was like i'm
against any identity politics and then
he goes
as an asian i believe x and then i said
whoa tim hold on that's a contradiction
like it's funny we all laugh
but do we advance our understanding of
and of these issues in any way when it's
funny and contradictory i don't know
i don't know yeah i think it's um
it's less productive than just setting
up
a dialogue with like actual experts
yeah right but i mean like i guess it
kind of gets the conversation started
that may be that may be
yeah i'll think about it more i
appreciate you bringing it up
okay thank you all right it's a good
question it is and
you know there's really arguments to be
made on both sides about that
uh i don't think it's uh i don't think
there's like a clear obvious and
and right answer one way or the other
let's go next to trey
from missouri trey you're on the air
can you hear me yes i can so
i've been kind of studying um voter
suppression and i've kind of wanted to
kind of drill down just briefly like do
republicans vote suppress
because they understand that if more
people vote we tend to lose
and why hasn't congress enacted on this
so there's a couple different questions
there yet republicans have admitted many
times
that the ways in which they suppress the
vote
they believe are good for them you can
go back to the mike turzai video from
2011 or 2012 where he says voter id will
deliver mitt romney
we'll deliver pennsylvania to mitt
romney in the 2012 election
you can go to the 2020 campaign with
trump saying
you know if democrats are able to do all
this stuff and getting all these people
voting will never win again like they
seem to know that in general
it being easier to vote is not
particularly good for them
in terms of why congress hasn't done
more this is a really great question
and one of the things i called for
earlier this week when we reported on
the 253 voter suppression bills that
republicans are pushing
across the country right now is that if
you have the house the senate and the
white house the way democrats do now
if you can't get something more
permanent down at the federal level on
voting
right now then arguably you you can
never do it
of course the reality is much more
complicated and you have to
understand that there are limitations to
you know states do run their own
elections
and so when you had the voting rights
act and the supreme court said okay
we're going to undo this
but this list of states needs to check
with us if they want to change laws
because they have a history of racially
based voter suppression
that's a rare sort of federal oversight
over how states run elections but for
the most part
states get to decide as long as it's not
straight up illegal or unconstitutional
which means you have to take each
decision to court one by one
it's basically a mess is the reason why
we can't just have the federal
government say
we're doing away with all of these voter
suppression tactics
all right i've been i'm i'm from
missouri so i've been keeping an eye on
our legislature and our legislators
you know been passing bills aimed at
making it harder to vote as a black man
you know i i fear that you know that's
directly targeted at me and so
i just wanted to i just wanted to ask
you and see you know what are your
thoughts on that and why
you know congress hasn't enacted and i
understand that you know with
people like joe manchin and kirsten
cinema making it hard for us to do
anything
uh to get stuff like the john lewis
voting rights act and
i just was curious to hear your thoughts
but yeah i think it's more complicated
than just
joe manchin may not may not go for it i
actually think that there's real
there there are legitimate issues about
federal supremacy when it comes to
election law
and um i i think it's a little more
complicated than that but i'm right with
you in that
right now democrats have the white house
house and senate
if they can't do something about this
issue now legislatively
arguably they never can or or they never
will
all right thanks for the call man my
pleasure thank you for calling
there is trey from missouri let's see
who else we can talk to how about mark
from framingham mark from framingham
you're on the air
hi uh can you hear me yes i can mark
hi um you recently expressed a wariness
about blanket student debt cancellation
and i'm just wondering what your reasons
for that are
yeah uh so i've kind of outlined it
before but i'm glad to sort of do it
again
uh i think that there should be some
debt cancellation and i'm sort of open
to hearing different ideas about what uh
level of debt cancellation that
should be i think the problem with just
a blanket debt cancellation for
everybody period
is that it is going to do a couple
different things that i don't think are
particularly good
one is it there should be some element
of it being
need based and need based i would define
it probably very differently
than than uh some others and my
threshold for what is need based would
would be
significant a lot of people would fall
under that but i don't see a reason
to just go in and cancel all the debt of
everybody
who went to really expensive schools
because that's what they chose to do
they could have gone to a cheaper school
they could afford to go to a more
expensive school took on some debt
because that's where they wanted to go
could have ended up without debt at a
cheaper school
and we're just going to say here just
take take all the money
and pay it off i also think that there's
people who have debt
forgiveness programs based on the fields
that they are in
if they work a certain amount of time in
a certain underserved area or whatever
the case may be so we're sort of saying
like let's throw even more money at a
problem that already has
a path to having some degree or even
full debt forgiveness
there um and it it it doesn't seem to me
to make sense to say everyone's student
debt
period is forgiven i want it to be
slightly more targeted than that
i want it to be more than 10 grand but i
don't think it's logical to say
just pay off everybody's debt period
i've not seen a good argument as to why
we would do that
you are still to there should be some
responsibility like listen
it's beyond your control that some
schools now cost 70k
that's insane the reason schools cost
70k
is because it's so easy to get student
loans so the school knows hey we'll go
from 65 to 70k
because it's easy to get student loans
we'll get the money then it'll be their
problem to figure out figure out how to
pay it off like
that's why i want some student loan debt
forgiveness
but to say full total and complete just
doesn't really make sense to me
economically culturally i've not seen a
good argument for it
okay would you mind if i maybe shared a
bit of my perspective on sure yeah no
please please
um so the way i see it is a lot of
people talk about how
people who hold a lot of student debt
tend to be on average higher income
because college graduates
on average on in the aggregate make more
money
um but the way i see it is that higher
income at some point
doesn't necessarily mean that much if
you also have more debt
for instance medical school debt on
average
on top of undergraduate um is 250k
for law school it's 150 k and it's kind
of like
if i run a business and i want to expand
i may have increased revenues but i also
have increased costs
yeah and in fact this has been studied
and while there is an
income premium to college degrees the
net worth premium
is significantly smaller because you
make more money but you have more debt
debt cancels out some of the more money
you have so yes you're absolutely right
the other thing i would point out is a
lot of college graduates
just because they have to go where the
jobs are they live in high cost of
living areas
so you know 100 grand um uh in new york
city
according to cnn money is equivalent to
40k
in houston so it's so it might sound a
lot on paper
but day to day it's not really that
effect um
so um and personally for me i
tend to lean more towards maybe helping
too many people or otherwise helping
people who maybe don't need that help
rather than risk not helping people who
do need that
totally agree with you that's my view
with all of these social welfare
programs that
you will always be able to find someone
who got a benefit
that you could argue didn't really
deserve it and i want the line to be
where there's a few people getting it
that don't deserve it
as long as everybody that does is
getting it and so for example i'm very
open to the idea of
there's a set amount of debt
cancellation
plus a multiplier based on some
combination of what is your income
and where do you live and cost of like
i'm totally up for that
it doesn't make sense to me to just say
we're cancelling
everybody's debt regardless of how much
it is regardless of how much you make
regardless regardless of where you live
how long ago
you uh uh obtained the debt how much you
know all this
i'm not there but i'm definitely at
let's
let's we've got to do more than 10k okay
um
yeah i definitely understand where
you're coming from i had um one last
question though
sure uh you've had people such as steve
keane and stephanie kelton as well as
dean baker on
yes these are people who are very
critical of the economic consensus and i
think you've expressed why we should be
skeptical
of a lot of mainstream economics however
i also think that especially with covet
and climate change
we should listen to expert consensus on
those
in those areas so is that inconsistent
on my part to be skeptical of the
economics profession but also be
trusting of the consensus
in the natural sciences no i don't think
so i don't think so and many
check out my interview with israeli
economist ariel rubinstein who recently
explained
economics is a study of what economists
believe
it's not like for example rocket science
climate science immunology
uh so no i i think it's perfectly
reasonable to look at economic thinking
in a different way than we look at for
example uh vaccine vaccine science i
think you're right to look at them as
two different things
okay yeah um it's also worth noting that
like um
um i was listening to what you said
earlier about cancer culture it's also
worth noting
because a lot of conservatives say like
oh universities are are left-leaning
but a lot of billionaires donate a lot
of money to universities
with the expectation that they hire
intellectuals
who will for lack of a better term serve
as mouthpieces for them like koch
brother
like the koch brothers donates a lot of
money to mit yeah
mit then becomes reluctant to hire
left-leaning economists
um so yeah it was great to talk to you
again i really appreciate uh
you taking my call um because i i really
appreciate speaking with you
all right thanks very much great to hear
from you that is going to do it for
calls today
i apologize to everybody i wasn't able
to get to but we will try it again and
we'll take a quick break
and be back after the the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week first one is
david based on the numbers we're seeing
about loyalty to donald trump and people
willing to leave the republican party if
he starts a new party
is it fair to say that donald trump's
voters are more loyal to him
than obama and biden's voters are loyal
to them
i think that there's a complexity to
this question because
uh what we mean by loyalty
may not be the same thing if what we
mean by
loyalty we mean lack of willingness to
criticize them in other words
you're loyal in that you'll never
criticize anything they do
i think that yes donald trump's
followers
are more loyal to him you see many on
the left
who vote for voted for biden voted for
obama
voted for obama for reelection and yet
had many criticisms
of them and some might say that that
means they're less loyal
i don't know i'm not so sure about that
i i think that
one of the things that does that is
unique to the trump voter
is that because many of them either were
sort of like disaffected republicans who
already had
some disdain for the republican party or
were brought into politics by trump and
if trump had been a democrat they would
have become democrats
trump ran as a republican so they're you
know putatively ostensibly republicans
they don't really care about the
republican party
and when you think about all of these
folks
who joined politics essentially
to follow donald trump they
liked the dog whistling on the
xenophobic
sort of racist stuff they don't really
care about
abortion like you know trump made up
this thing about how he used to be
pro-choice now he's pro-life because he
met a kid he liked or something like
that
uh at 68 and then he became pro-life and
so that appealed to some of the
evangelicals
most historical republicans went with
trump because they weren't going to go
for hillary but
the people that trump brought in they
don't really care about most of the
stuff that a lot of republicans care
about they'll go with it if trump wants
it but
they're not really about the debt
they're not really about abortion
they're not really about religious
liberty
they liked the sort of vibe of trump
and the dog whistling that came with it
trump came in and he said
you know george w bush was wrong on the
war and mitt romney sucks and i
you know john mccain i prefer war heroes
who don't get captured and obama might
not even be american and
the mexican rapists and all this
different stuff and that was really what
they were
motivated by and so it's less to me
that they are super loyal to trump it's
that they don't really care about
anything else that's going on in the
political world they never really cared
about anything
other than trump's words even trump's
actions they don't really care about
remember
about seven eight months into trump's
presidency i got a call from some guy in
california i think it was
who said you know trump's just the best
everything he's done is the best
and i said well what has he actually
done so far and he didn't actually list
anything
and i said well what motivated you to
vote for trump what promises did you
like and he said building the wall
i said okay so if there's no wall across
the entire border in november of 2020
you're not voting for trump and he said
no i'm probably still voting for trump
they don't really care about issues they
they care about trump
because of the things he says and how he
says them and in that way
it's a debate whether you call it
loyalty
or simply they don't care enough about
anything else
to consider abandoning donald trump i
think it's the latter
you tell me whether the term loyalty
does or doesn't apply
david if joe biden doesn't run in 2024
does anybody other than kamala harris
have a shot
i think this is an interesting question
i imagine that if joe biden doesn't run
for re-election
and kamala does there will be a
challenge
from the more progressive left but
whether it is likely to succeed depends
on things that i don't think have very
much to do
with kamala harris let me explain
the success of the biden administration
over the next few years and whether
donald trump runs in 2024
in my mind are the big factors that will
influence
whether kamala harris sails into
the 2024 nomination if joe biden doesn't
doesn't run for re-election
that makes it very difficult to predict
this far in advance
because uh right now
you could say kamala harris would be the
likely nominee
as vp but if the biden presidency
is a disaster um and by that i mean
public opinion agrees overwhelmingly
that the biden
presidency has been a disaster i think
harris
very well could be the nominee but she
just won't win on the other hand
if the biden presidency does very well
i don't think there's any way anybody
has a shot at uh
unseating her for the nomination if
indeed she
chooses to run so i i think that if i'm
kamala harris
what i'm doing is taking a as visible a
role as possible in the administration
certainly more visible than she's played
so far but we're only what is it five
five six weeks in um it would be
probably a good idea for kamala harris
to find some area and to be seen as a
leader in that specific area
she's been doing a lot of biden's
sidekick which is fine
biden did a lot of being obama's
sidekick as well
but eventually it would be great for her
name to be attached to something you
know with biden
although you know we could say it didn't
go as far as we wanted wanted it to go
uh biden was the sort of experience
with foreign diplomacy guy and the
taking on
the issue of cancer and and medical
research
particularly in in the context of of his
son
uh dying of brain cancer and whether
that is good or bad
having something i think will be good
for kamal o'hara some kind of project of
of her own um if trump runs in 2024
it almost may not matter whether the
biden administration
is or isn't successful and it may not
even matter whether kamala harris is or
isn't the nominee
it will again become this kind of wacky
turnout thing where it's a combination
of
republicans who dislike the democrat
more than they dislike trump kind of
holding their noses and voting for
him which is just a fraction of them
most of them like trump but there's
enough there that they can make a
difference
combined with whether people go out uh
people who don't really care about
politics traditionally go out and vote
for donald trump
and it'll be less relevant whether
kamala harris is or isn't the nominee so
the the point is there are way too many
variables right now making predictions
makes makes very little sense we should
be focused on 2022
removing the trumpian members of the
house in 2022
and joe biden has to start putting
things on his list of accomplishments
covet relief of course being at the
absolute top david do you think
political beliefs should be a protected
class
like religion national origin ethnicity
and race
this is a really good question my
general
view for a long time has been things
that are personal choices
shouldn't be protected classes there
should be
the possibility of consequences for the
choices that you make now
this is very easy when it comes to some
people don't choose their race
people don't choose their ethnicity
people don't choose their sexual
orientation
people don't choose their nationality
where they were born people don't choose
for example to have a physical
disability
these are things that are beyond our our
control
and we off typically we also can't
control
that they are visible to others now you
might say well nationality is not really
visible just by looking at someone
well but maybe okay there are cases
where it's not
uh but it's certainly not self-professed
i can't say
i'm norwegian and now i'm norwegian
so so uh that i think is is an important
thing
what are sort of inborn characteristics
or things beyond our control versus
things that are that are really just
choices now that puts religion outside
of protected class i understand that
religion is a protected class
both membership in or lack of membership
in religion that is a protected class in
the united states
by this self-professed standpoint
religion would be outside of it and that
would be antithetical to what many think
the united states is about now on the
other hand
sexual orientation in many states still
isn't
a protected class i believe that it
should be
political beliefs not currently a
protected class
other than in washington dc so you can
discriminate against people based on
their political beliefs
in florida you could say we don't allow
democrats in this place
and that would be legal um
there is a way in which political
beliefs are protected which is the first
amendment
um and the the government cannot
punish you or abridge your ability to
speak
about what your political views are but
uh that doesn't mean there aren't
consequences to your political beliefs
if you decide to sort of
state them now there are complexities
with political beliefs in terms of a
protected class because
political beliefs are so broad and i'll
give you some examples
if i say as an example
the treasury of the united states
is a terrible institution
and it's a scam or so you know whatever
that's a political belief and people
might disagree but like the consequences
of that or the possibility of my belief
about the treasury having consequences
it's sort of more abstract and difficult
to imagine like it's hard to imagine
somebody getting fired because of their
view
about the treasury unless maybe they
work for the treasury okay fair
on the other hand you could argue that
someone has a political belief
that um you know that it should be legal
uh to that i don't even know that that
jewish people and black people
shouldn't be allowed to hold public
office okay imagine imagine that
um that also is a political belief
which many of us would imagine would
realistically have consequences with an
employer as an example an employer finds
out
well we have black people and jewish
people who who work here
and that's something we we just that's
bad for
for what's going on here and so that's a
political belief which
we believe should get someone fired we
don't want somebody working with that if
you pull
if you protect political beliefs as a
protected class
would an employer no longer be able to
fire someone for something like that
i think it's very very difficult
extraordinarily difficult
my view is i don't believe political
beliefs should be a protected class
i think to the extent that um
political beliefs are protected by the
first amendment
uh that's fine and that's sufficient
but i can't think of a reason to add
political beliefs as a protected class
you can also just shut up if you're in
an environment where your political
beliefs may be problematic you can shut
up
if you're black there's no way you can
say oh in this environment i will
prevent people from knowing i'm black
if you have a physical disability that
puts you in a wheelchair
you can't say that might be seen
negatively in this context
so i will just hide the fact that i'm in
a wheelchair from peop
you can't do it so so my view is
do not list political beliefs as a
protected class i think religious
beliefs are a question mark but i
understand the historical reality
of religious belief and non-belief as
protected in the united states so i'm
not
advocating for its removal from a
protected class
let me know your thoughts on this i
think that the the the broadness
of political belief is what makes this
quite uh
quite complicated we've got a great
bonus show for you today
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com
pakman of the people is a new platform
matching local campaigns with supporters
and donors from across the country
sort of like a yelp for local candidates
you can filter by policy and location
and you can support the next generation
of leaders check it out
at of the people.us